welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss this is philip molina hey buddy
hey how's it going hey this is a big
question it's new rockstar's new q a
show we're going to answer your biggest
questions
about all things nerdy the kind of weird
questions that really
no one should spend time researching the
kind of geek grenades that philip and i
could jump on
all day we're also going to be answering
fan mail questions we got
a little freaking question box that
is full of personal questions for us
there were some gross ones that we got
and we had to ignore them this time but
also we drank a little before we started
just a little bit
sorry let's get started philip and i
have each selected a big question
to assign to each other to answer it's
kind of a little challenge
we got your help with it though philip
my question to you came from at macho my
nacho
and this is a question i've always
wondered how much
does thor's hammer i almost had cap
stamber you almost
picked it up karen's hammer how much
does mjolnir weigh
exactly you've always wondered this i
have wondered good because i've got an
answer for you
but also i'm not qualified to really
answer this so i'm trying here so
call me out it's fine but also you're
bullying a
person who's admitting their faults uh
all right first of all okay
i did do a lot of research and a lot of
math on this great thor's hammer
did actually start out as being
incredibly
massively heavy in norse mythology oh
sure that it wasn't about worthiness it
was literally like
too dang heavy well to the norse people
uh strength equals worthiness there's no
other qualities
so not only did the only people that
could steal thor's hammer wasn't they
were worthy is that there were three
giant trolls
who together can lift his hammer and so
they were just like able to take it
thor himself literally wears a weight
belt in order in order
does it have a name but
there's no way that that's that's what's
going on here it's obviously
much more complicated so i also went
into the marvel archives
yeah exactly it weighs 42.3 pounds right
or you know one eric yes no yeah you're
mostly front
yeah i'm all front baby that's sexy so
the issue with that though is that
that's actually an old figure and it
didn't really account for
the way we've seen thor's hammer
expressed in the mcu that's true the
film hammer is different yeah 42.3
pounds
is liftable theoretically i've heard
that you could probably lose theoretical
yeah yeah you've lifted that all right
i've lifted one eric so
many times so 42.3 pounds doesn't
actually make sense for the
way it it behaves in the mcu this is
gonna
immediately get super weird i'm so
excited it changes
depending on who's lifting it and so
first you remember the you remember
higgs boson yeah
uh particle right the higgs boson
particle you're right
uh the the whole large agent collider
thing yes where
everyone thought it was gonna be the end
of the world but actually proved the
existence of the higgs boson particles
theoretical the god particle okay yeah
it proved the existence of god
and we all changed and became what we
are that's not the only theoretical
particle that is currently
interesting in science there's another
particle called
it's just straight up called the
graviton i confuse the first step with
the gravitron
which is the worst ride i've ridden the
graviton before and i've had other
people's vomit slap me a little bit on
the cheek no a graviton
is the theoretical particle that gives
mass an increase or decreased feeling
when you go to lift it depending on your
relative distance to
another heavenly body so for instance on
earth something feels like it weighs
42.3 pounds in space
the mass of it doesn't change then why
does it feel like it changes
theoretically there's a different
particle in some ways invisible to us
that is actually changing the amount of
how much the thing
kind of weighs and is this related to
whether you're on earth or the moon or
jupiter or pluto yeah
kind of super theoretical but we have
some guesses of the way it works it
feels like it has to be coming into play
with thor's hammer because you could
think easily hey thor's hammer is magic
shut up phillip i mean you might be
thinking shut up phillip anyway odin's
whisper
my favorite song
we know this about asgardians what do
they famously say about magic it's
what we call science right it's just
that they're so far advanced with their
science
that we think of it as magic but it uses
the rules of science now we know that
it's not as simple as magic because when
someone goes to lift
it it's not that they aren't strong
enough now if they don't get weaker
it's as if it's very heavy it is a mass
thing the easiest way to see it is in
the scene where the avengers variously
try to lift it
and you watch iron man he's using tech
to try to lift it right and the tech is
not necessarily worthy or unworthy but
the tech
is using like jet engines yeah it's
applying a force to it yeah
and it is the magic isn't making the
tech less capable
and it's way more easy to see what's
actually happening when you see the hulk
lift it because the hulk goes to lift it
but he's actually starting to
create a downward force next to him on
the ground underneath his feet and you
see that the ground starts to crack oh
he's
smushing himself into the ground right
into nothing yeah plato so that
tells us for fact that the force
is essentially being redirected but it's
not that the hulk got weaker or
something or he wasn't able to do it
so force being relative to mass
means that the mass is actually at play
here and the mass
is changing along with the force so this
is where
it continues to get super weird it is
based on by the way just newton's third
yeah i was going to say like a action
equals a reaction that will get
redirected somewhere
so the more force that they're putting
in the more force that is working
against them
but it's not working against them in
their muscles it feels like this thing
is changing weight and it's getting
heavier
but in a very exact way so it's actually
kind of weirdly roughly able to do
a little bit of math on this right i
love that you did math
well and it's not accurate don't use
this
and not in a life or destination at
least we do know that if you were to
create a formula for the weight of this
hammer
42.3 pounds is a consistent amount that
part does not change
that's consistent constant no matter
what no matter if you're worthy or not
worthy
however if you're unworthy as determined
by the hammer
which probably means that it is doing
some sort of snapshot assessment
of all the gross dirty loads it's just
giving you like an up and down look like
yeah yeah it's just a black light not
worthy uh so
when it activates a black light sees
you're not worthy then it
kicks in a new graviton base
essentially the uru metal that makes uh
thor's hammer is probably why it's it's
special
because it's unique yeah yeah unique
metal so it can actually give off
gravitons if you think of them as
particles that have
a consistent mass themselves which we
have a theoretical number of what that
mass
is oh my god uh here it's on screen but
i because i forgot to write it down in
front of me
if you take the force that is being
applied just say we're playing we're a
lifting force of maybe a thousand pounds
we're a strong man on
one of those uh competitions on tv that
lifting force and you divide it
by the mass of a single graviton that
would tell you how many gravitons now
need to be
added to the weight of the hammer in
order for the hammer to feel
like it's the exact opposite amount of
force you're applying you multiply that
by the weight of a single graviton which
is that tiny tiny number
and now we know the additional weight
that has been added
to the hammer 42.3 plus
exactly the amount of added weight or
mass
that is the amount of force that you
gave into it so
for an unworthy like either of us speak
for yourself
42.3 pounds plus the exact
force that you're able to apply is
dynamically being added
to the 42.3 pounds and giving thor's
hammer
a relative weight that constantly
changes to exactly the amount of force
that you're applying to it
but if you happen to be thor or cap it
zeros out the amount of gravitons
zeroing out that half of the equation
and adding up to still just 42.3
that sounds like an exact answer
i feel like we could have just measured
chris hemsworth bicep
i tried this route i'm not kidding i
looked up there are new videos of chris
new not new dude nude i saw your face
i'm gonna look later yeah i saw your
nose perk up
he has this like huge massive bicep in
his new workout videos
the one on camera because i was like he
doesn't look like he's lifting that much
on camera the
prop masters uh made that one to only be
like 13 pounds
because he needs to wield it so much
yeah okay and then yeah after four takes
of that then uh you're not so much of an
avenger anymore
how much did you start drinking before
we started i won't tell
how about we take a break yeah well
we'll come back with
the next uh question that you wanted
answered after a quick message from
people we care about
hey guys eric here just a reminder that
new rockstars is offering exclusive
rewards to our patrons in the form of
bonus videos each month
for november i did an in-depth breakdown
of the opening sequence of raiders of
the lost ark
and how it's so perfectly defined
indiana jones as a hero and foreshadowed
everything to follow in that film
including nazi's heads exploding you can
get exclusive access to that video along
with lots of other behind the scenes
content
and just a general good feeling of
helping this channel grow by becoming an
official patron of new rockstar's
digital studios
just go to patreon.com newrockstars
again that's patreon.com
newrockstars all right we're back we got
refills this feels fun
yeah i'm having a good time my brain is
tired though so i'm glad that it gets to
be your turn now okay
i assigned eric a question that i got
from this guy is great at grandpa
glow which i imagine he's a character on
glow that hasn't been revealed yet
uh okay he wants to know how old is
cap now but it's a two-parter and
is he gonna die soon i feel like your
second question is
is the real question yeah that's like
like casually like
hey hell does he okay well um i loved
that i got to
answer this question because it is like
it's on our minds
there's so much mystery around cap at
the end of end game it's just this old
man shows up
where has he been he's been on this
bench for 100 years
is he just how many ducks does he watch
to live and die from
as he's fed them okay well we do know
that cap ages very slowly thanks to the
super soldier serum so he doesn't age
normally he also has his big like
wrinkle in his life not just on his face
because he
was in ice sleeping for what like 67
years
so that also just puts a big like blip
in the middle of his life
yeah so sorry did you go about this more
like his biological age or his age
as a birth certificate i went by every
possible way in an attempt to answer
this question definitively okay so cap
was born birth certificate
1918 and then he lived for about 27
years he went into the ice in 1945
okay and there he stayed for six decades
or so 67 years later in 2011 they thawed
him back out and there he continued to
age normally but not totally normally
because he had the super soldier serum
so it slowed that process down
by how much we're not exactly sure but
we have a general estimate of it
after 2011 he lived for another 12 or 13
more years
to the events of avengers end game pass
the blip it's now 2023 or so
and they are able to defeat thanos and
then he goes
back in time which is where the whole
mystery begins because he goes back in
time to live with peggy
the writers confirmed 1948 and then
continued to live on
some life we never saw what that life
was whether he used his knowledge of the
future to prevent horrible things like
jfk's assassination
good investments in facebook yeah that's
probably what it was the numbers we do
have on this come
from two different sources there are two
different vfx
producers who worked on this one is jen
underdoll who's a visual effects
producer who works for marvel
entertainment
who said in a wired interview what would
a super soldier look like if he aged
106 years now it's not a difference if
that means a difference of 106 years
like plus 160 years age
two or that's how old he is now there
was another source trent klaus who works
for low level fx that is the
team that marvel commissioned to produce
that effect
um so this is produced by they're the
artists who are literally going in there
pixel by the way this is who ages humans
yes uh yeah they're controlling all of
our aging processes
he said in an interview i think the
technical age we came up with was
119 years old he would be at that point
in time
but with the serum he was supposed to
land roughly
85 to 95 somewhere in that age
younger than what a normal human would
look like so
we're able to kind of go back and see
how they got those numbers uh 106 jen
underdolls numbers would mean that cap's
second life with peggy
last 67 years which is interesting
because that's also how long it is
frozen for and in that alternate
timeline around the year 2015
would be when he would jump back to give
sam the shield in our timeline so 2015
if you think about it
that would be around the time hank pym
meets scott lang
and his pen particles are now back on
the scene so he would be able to find
him
2015's also around the time peggy carter
would have died right i was just
thinking she
still dies he didn't super soldier yeah
she's still selfishly
yeah he could have made her live longer
why didn't he give her a chance real
quick i'll say if he if she died in 2015
how what year do we see him on the bench
that was 2023 or 2024. so
eight or or nine years have passed since
peggy's dead we don't know what he's up
to in this time too
that would be in the version of time
travel that he lives within our timeline
and he's just been hanging out still
saying i want old man cap in falcon in
the winter soldier
yes a guiding force we hope so that he
is going to be a mentor figure
now if we're going by the 119 number
that's a number i like
better and there's a couple reasons why
in cap's second life with peggy that he
lives that would mean that would have
lasted 80 years
which sounds like a nice round number
that someone's like let's say he lives a
life of 80 years with her
and that would mean in his alternate
timeline the year would be 2028
which is in the future and there's some
kind of technology presumably that gets
invented that doesn't exist currently in
2023
and that would really be the only
explanation for how he could use this
other new time travel
form that doesn't exist yet because it
doesn't make sense how he shows up at
the end of the movie no matter how
different
even if he doesn't keep going and
getting more pin particles because it's
not just pin particles you would have to
like
go back down to that theoretical branch
that no longer exists
and then like make a weird like 30
degree turn to like end up back up to
this one
it's it's weird because when you go back
you change things and the new timelines
get formed
so you know the writers the directors
didn't totally think it out so that's
why
you can say like oh it was 2028 all
kinds of elon musk came up with this
whole new thing in 2026
and that's what came out elon musk
exists in the marvel universe he does
and tony stark also does
yeah in iron man 2 elon musk oh you're
right makes a cameo
and they like hang out in uh in monaco i
like how pathetic elon musk is in their
world
yeah i made tesla's 119 also with the he
said the appearance would be
the age 85 years old that would mean
crunching those numbers the super
soldier serum causes cap
to age 20 to 30 percent slower
than the average human does so if you
think about this in the 13 years between
caps defrosting at the end of captain
america the first avenger and adventures
in game
chris evans aged the actor aged seven
years in that time
but he never ages up stark gets more
gray hair
a thor gets fat banner turns into hulk
banner
black widow her hair changes they all
change in different ways
but they kept chris evans exactly the
same as much as they could
to show that his super soldier serum is
having this effect on him the
the other point i want to make here is
that the actor that they use is a
stand-in his name is patrick gorman
and when they shot this uh he was like
the stand-in and they put chris evans
face on him and he's the oldest face
he's the old guy
he's a stand-in actor he's done a bunch
of different stuff yeah he's 85 years
old right now when they shot this movie
he was 83 years old so
i think the 119 number of this is is the
better number so the conclusion
i believe based off of all the numbers
we have shown in based on the aging
evidence we can look at
cap currently in the mcu is 119 years
old that old man cap is 119 years old
but has the the still
amazing body of a 83 year old man or 85
years old
now it's worth pointing out the cap's
body his
body has been in existence for 186
years he was just frozen for a lot of it
so this tissue has like
seen earth's time pass for 186 years so
it's hard to measure
age if you're just going by birth
certificate or based off of
that person's experience of time passing
oh yeah so you're saying cap
is almost 200 years almost uh yeah a
double the centenarian or whatever you
call that
he has perceived 119 years past so
that's you know there are people who
have kind of lived upwards of that long
but he has the body of an 85 year old
yeah ooh tight 85 years old but the
scary question
is he gonna die soon will he die soon i
think not there are some rumors that he
will appear in falcon winter soldier as
kind of a guiding mentor figure so
hopefully and i hope he never dies my
hope is that he
well no one's like i hope cap does he
lives and lives and lives and watches
all of his friends and loved ones and
all the flowers and all the animals and
the
skyscrapers rise and crumble around him
and he's there
like wally why does this have a warm
romantic energy to it but you're
describing the saddest
existence where everything dies around
him what if he's immortal now and he
can't die no matter how many things are
thrown at him
you just want this for yourself yeah i
just think there's some kind of
beautiful poetry in that
and that's that's cap now so it's a it's
a sad existence that he lives in
no matter what he's sad yeah he's sad
it's why are we asking about his age we
should ask about his emotions
so uh there's your answer fish bulb i'm
so sad now
about it that's why you don't ask an
avengers age you'll never get an answer
you like i do like that he'll outlive us
yeah no matter what
and that makes me feel safe yeah secure
i want to be tucked into my grave gently
by captain yeah
speaking of tucked into our graves uh
these questions are definitely gonna end
it all for us
these are questions that you guys sent
about us
and we don't exactly know what's in here
but uh
we're trying to be a bit unfiltered
though uh an off-screen producer may
have helped us a little bit
you guys can actually mail us straight
up fan mail
or regular mail you don't have to like
us but then don't send us anything weird
uh but there is an address uh on screen
right now and then also
in the description uh of this all you
guys can send us stuff direct and we'll
we'll show it off on the show
and include uh some questions like these
mandy that sounds fake
mandy asks which fan base has the most
intimidating fans oh that's a really
scary question to answer because they're
intimidating uh we have a lot of like
different properties that we cover here
and i would say
as of right now i don't know about you
philip i think
the rick and morty fans are the most
intimidating because there's
they're they have the highest iq but
they also got to be a genius
you have to be a genius to understand
the jokes but like there's they're the
quickest to point out if you get just
something wrong or something they
disagree with
you can't really win basically like you
can you can point out like a detail
that you think is an interesting subtle
detail and if they already saw that
detail they'll yell at you you pointed
to an audio recording
yeah they're like no i already saw that
because
you know but they're the least grateful
of all of our fans like we we do stuff
for like marvel fans and they're just so
grateful that the mcu exists right now
whereas the the rick and morty fans are
probably the hardest to please to
defend them for a second marvel fans
have just gotten like the like time of
their lives win after win
rick and morty fans and that right now
have to be like oh great it was two
years for five episodes
it was cool we'll get five episodes more
in the other side of this
year i'm gonna say star wars fans are
still just the classic
yeah specifically the word most
intimidating
and this arm is the dark side don't join
the dark side yeah they are the og
like no one hates star wars more than
star wars fans exactly and i do
love nerding out about star wars with
the star wars fan because they're like
oh my god they you know there's that guy
that cries every time a teaser trailer
comes out oh sure
and he makes me cry when i watch his
videos because he's just so impassioned
and i
love that but that same passion
translates to
you are so wrong you need to do your
research before you open your mouth
yeah i'm like i i mean i just said hi
you know like
they they can find especially because
they have star wars legends in their
head
and star wars legends has all kinds of
stuff that is not canon but they want
you to know
that a lot of stuff used to be canon and
so you have to also be balancing all
that
you have to be so well researched to
even have a conversation yeah with star
wars
that's true and the star wars uh fan
base spans generations like since 1977.
which should be beautiful
it should be a good thing but there's
multiple generations of heartbreak there
too like starting 97 is when people are
like
wait what is why is boba fett
in this scene now and he's supposed to
be why is the emperor looking like this
like
that's when why is greedo's shooting
first and now there's
children who are watching the disney
plus star wars saying why does grita say
mcclunky
what does that mean i bet you have my
monkey
[Music]
97 is also the same year where i learned
about the the rough side of trying to be
a star wars fan where i was getting into
seventh grade and i um
got to redo my bedroom and uh they were
doing a phantom menace
uh sale on qvc and i asked my dad to
order
all phantom menace gear like i wanted a
huge darth maul
tapestry that was going to cover the
whole back wall and then i had shelves
for all the figurines
a number of them were jar jar related
and right as
like my dad was like placing the order
my sister just walked in and stopped
everyone she goes guys everyone stop
and she walked right up to me she goes
phillip is this
cool oh and i was like yeah she goes is
it cool
and i didn't order any of it and i just
had plain white walls
and then i got kicked out of that room
eventually which is a whole other look
you know you've rose above you've built
an
entire home of filled with star wars
stuff and my sister
still doesn't think i'm cool so take
that christina
just keep chasing that high i just want
her
approval all right what what else uh
next one landon
tears have you ever had something happen
to you as a child that you didn't
understand what it meant until later i
think we just heard
phillip i had uh actually you're the one
who who
explained to me what this meant philip
like a couple years ago
said because i had this story that i i
raised you i was your father that's what
this sounds like i didn't understand
until i was a man i would get picked up
from school
with with my siblings my mom on mondays
if we were good
would take us by mcdonald's to go get um
like ice cream
and we would good mom good mom good mom
happy mother's day
i would always get like a hot fudge
sundae and i didn't like getting peanuts
on it and
i was like six you were there
i was 31 years old and um one time they
put peanuts on it and i didn't want it
every time we went to that drive-through
the woman who worked there she would
look at me
and i would tell this is like the
punchline of the story not realizing it
was a punchline
she said i remember you no nuts
and phillips started laughing and i'm
like yeah it's a cute story right he's
like
yeah this woman called you no nuts yeah
repeatedly
and i went back and told my siblings
like did you laugh at the story because
it was cute that she just remembered i
didn't like nuts
or that she said no nuts they're like
yeah i said she called a little blinding
at six year old boy no nuts every time
they gave you a mean nickname you got
bullied at mcdonald's
and i would sing it to myself like
that's right no no i'm no nuts
pleased to meet you yeah i don't know
hot fudge sundae because he has a good
no nuts
yeah go to the hot dog saying no weiner
please i'm no wiener
i'm so sorry about that i remember that
i'm glad you told me because i'm
happy that i know now yeah and you went
back and you found her she was still
there yeah she's still there she goes
hey
nuts yeah come back yeah more and you
guys are engaged now right yeah it's
beautiful
uh i actually do remember it's a quick
one that uh when i
i was i went to the beach with my mom
and her sassy friend once and i was like
six or seven the sassy friend of the
name uh uh blanca
the the the name from uh street fighter
i'm assuming that's where she got it
and i i was you know doing that thing
where like you when you're a little boy
you want to bring presents to your
mother
and so i was gathering um a bunch of uh
shells
to like present to my mother and i kept
bringing them over like and
you know it didn't win any more love or
anything but it i kept doing it
and then i felt bad that i didn't give
one to her friend and so i
brought one over and it was kind of this
like long cylindrical one and i handed
it over to her but she said like a quick
spanish phrase to my mom and they both
kind of like started laughing
for years i would just play that in my
head of like that phrase she said that
phrase she said
and then i got bullied in spanish at
once and i started to learn some curse
words
and i realized she said i'm gonna shove
this in me like the dick it is
but i was a little boy and she was
saying it to my mom she's like oh i'm
gonna shove this little [ __ ] in me
what bullying did you undergo yeah they
called me what did they say to you they
called me
one yeah and so uh
so then i learned in that moment that my
that my mom's friend is a
and um a drunk uh and kind of [ __ ]
wonka if you're watching this uh
oh god these are not questions that we
should ever be
answering do we have one more question
we do and hopefully it's uh g-rated
jeff fake jeff asks what's the funniest
thing you've ever heard someone
say in a movie screening oh we have a
lot of these stories right because we
you know we share all our stories we
share all of our stories when i saw
avengers end game
a second time or i think it was the
third time i saw it with my girlfriend
and it wasn't as packed that night
although it was like the monday after it
was still pretty busy in the theater
there was a kid who brought his dad
there and his dad was just like not into
marvel comics he's just like who is this
was he
like in the superman movie that we
watched he was like
not paying attention he was like falling
asleep in the sun and being like oh look
cat picked up the hammer that's a big
deal and dad's like oh girls are
bothering me
and at the end of the movie old cap
shows up and the dad
perks up and he the movie theater silent
he elbows his son and goes hmm that's
clint eastwood
and this one's just like shut up i had
to like stifle laughter
because the dad was so confident he's
like hey it's clint eastwood
he woke up to connect with his son like
the one thing
clooney swift it was not clint eastwood
but
what i liked that dad still thinks he's
like hey they got clinton
for that superhero movie pretty cool
good on them
the only thing that's coming to mind
right now is this that time that we but
we wrote that we both went to go see
1408 oh yeah
and there's a moment in the middle of
the movie where it's very
it's like 48 minutes into the movie or
something there's a countdown timer
starts that's right that's like if you
don't uh deal with this
you will die by the end of the movie
yeah and it's counting down from 60
minutes and there's an hour left in the
movie
and then uh one girl like an older
gentlewoman i hit her friend she goes
hey hey there's only a minute left in
the movie come on
watch it she thought it was one minute
countdown to the movie was suddenly
gonna
end we were what like a half an hour
into this 40 40 minutes in yeah
i mean it would have been that movie
could have ended right there to be fair
but yeah
in one minute they're gonna wrap all
this up i love that i love people like
getting things wrong
out loud as you're watching a movie with
them oh yeah the cocky eddie is my
favorite character
yeah yeah i know i've seen this trick
before just
60 seconds left yeah guys you can also
send us
questions about things that are more on
brand for us i would have to
answer that anything not anything
anything eric's really pushing for some
weird stuff to show up in these boxes
but that's it for this week's episode of
big question
that's right yeah we did it we we've
been wanting to do this show forever
just like to to
really geek out on stuff and not be
judged for it did you judge me
no but my sister called in and called us
both nerds yeah blanca said something
really offensive
really gross yeah uh now reminder to hit
us up with your questions next week you
can use the hashtag what big question
bigquestion works and uh hit us at new
rockstars on social media
uh or in the comments and uh we're gonna
be looking for everything because we
want this to be our chance to like
interact with you
we'll do it for your questions deep dive
big old questions
explain we'll do small weird fat old
questions
thanks to everyone who submitted
questions for this episode and uh let's
thank ourselves
philip thank you eric thank you this has
been really fun
i can't wait to do this more and more
you mean drink at work yeah
see you next week
[Music]
you